or il ya vingt ans j'ai commencé à
écrire les unit et il y a deux fabienne
larouche scénariste qui nous a donné de
grandes séries comme virginie et
productrice on pense à une taie neuf et
on vous parle de la maison vous êtes une
marathonienne de l'écriture de la
production quel est votre routine
ma routine je vis en confinant de 30 ans
c'est la réalité ce ne fut pas
disciplinés vous ce travail à la maison
depuis 30 ans alors il ya une protestion
pour moi d'aller travailler à montréal
dans un duo pour moi ça c'est ce que
demande antinomiques massif occasion
assez antinomique avec la notion de
création tg1 univers que vous êtes dans
mon bureau il faut souvent que va
exécuter le bureau de pierre mon bureau
et je travaille à londres
et puis c'est là que se passe de toute
la journée j cl bon il va sortir du
bureau pour halilhodzic est une journée
normale comme vous vivez au bureau mais
c'est comme ça vous détenez le record de
l'auteur solo qui a écrit le plus
longtemps une même série télévisée je
parle bien sûr de virginie 1740 épisodes
on s'en souvient ça se passe dans le
monde de l'enseignement à la question
qui s'impose c'est comment faites-vous
pour durer dans le temps
1740 épisodes et sans jamais jamais
manqué d'imagination
ces capitaux a même si c'est pour se
moucher l'inspiration à 10 partout effet
les paniers de avis monde de mon mari
qui rupture est née vries mais on arrive
à l'hôpital sacré-coeur deux moteurs
soit bien que t'attends pas à petit
nathan peau à l'urgence que les autres
at on appris que quand est en danger de
mort / ame à l'hôpital ça prend pas de
temps donc l'eau vient l'idée de trauma
parce que j'aurai encore un autre sorte
de médecine alors tout à coup
je passe deux semaines trois semaines
avec ces gens liés aux épis ouais je
vois des histoires autour de boîte
voilà alors c'est comme cela que ça bien
l'enseignement c'était ça pour virginie
30 10 sorties michel c'était son métier
mon mari puisque l'appui
mon idée est intéressante parce que tu
as envie raconte pas des histoires alors
sa vie partout où l'inspiration way est
partout puis après c'est la façon de te
raconter des copies évidemment faut
travailler c'est beaucoup de travail
je suis votre carrière depuis quoi les
25 dernières années en quoi la fait bien
de la rodia 25 ans quitte à peut être un
peu plus rock'n'roll est différent de la
fabienne larouche d'aujourd'hui un peu
plus sage posée mais plus vieille tout
ce que je vous disais moi d'illusions
c'est se battre ça fait 30 ans que ça ne
j'ai passé des du meilleur au pays
épisode je parle pas de la qualité des
séries je pense juste de d'illusions
haute et de pensée j'avais une certaine
naïveté sur toutes sortes de choses que
j'ai pu aujourd'hui
en même temps si je ne veux pas d'amener
cynique non plus mais je suis pas mal
j'ai pas mal du sud
ce prince sera probablement ma plus
grande qualité présentement c'est la
lucidité
c'est ça
côté district 31 c'est un méga succès
pour commencer à tourner le 13 juillet
vous avez plus d'un tour dans votre sac
fabienne larouche avec la distanciation
sociale des scènes de combat des
poursuites
comment ça va se passer avec un montage
comment ça va se passer
à ce moment là j'en ai aucune idée
la situation évolue de jour en jour on
va se le dire de ces lieux présentement
quand même mais on a aménagé pour être
capable de garder la distance de 2 m
s'il fallait que tout à coup ça soit
plus de mal face à soi un maître garde
tant mieux pour nous maintenant on
laissait une expérience et un tel
objectif
de travail je vois derrière vous dans un
de vos tiroirs je crois c'est le
scénario de terre de sang un projet sur
lequel vous travaillez depuis cinquante
une saga historique qui doit se dérouler
au xviie siècle à ce que ça va bientôt
être prêt je veux une belle sérénité je
veux prendre mon temps c'est pas souvent
imprimons autant cloche pas mort tu as
tes cris mais j'ai réécrit je réécris je
réécris puis quand ça va être le tabac
ça va être le temps mais une fois dans
ma ville je prends mon temps d'écrire
ses formidables bien d'avoir sa merci
beaucoup fabien la ruche dans ma très
grands faisaient là vous merci beaucoup
bah ça me fait grand plaisir merci à
vous